R
STUPID POLITICAL SPEECH, BUT
THEY CAN'T CONTROL THEMSELVES.
EVER.
CANDACE OWEN JOINS US WITH
REACTION.
I WOULD LOVE TO SEE SOMEONE DIE
IN THIS COUNTRY WITHOUT GETTING
A LECTURE POSTHUMOUSLY.
YOU DIED BECAUSE OF SMOKING,
DIDN'T GET THE VAX, DRIVING THAT
SUV.
CAN'T WE ACKNOWLEDGE DEATH IS A
SAD THING, GIVE IT THE
REVERENCE, AND MOVE ON?
>> NOT IF YOU'RE A MEMBER OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, BECAUSE
THEY'RE PSYCHOPATHS.
THIS IS THE SAME IDEOLOGY THAT
TAKES PLACE WITH SCHOOL
SHOOTINGS.
WAIT A MINUTE, THERE ARE
SCHOOLCHILDREN THAT ARE DEAD,
YOU NEED GIVE US MORE POWER.
THE FACT THEY THINK ABOUT
CONSUMING MORE POWER, WHEN
TRAGEDY STRIKES, IS AN EXAMPLE
OF THEY'RE UTTER PSYCHOPATHS.
WHAT'S GOING ON IS EXTREME
TRAGEDY, BUT IT'S A NATURAL
TRAGEDY.
THE EARTH HAS HURRICANES.
IF THERE WAS NO HUMAN BEINGS
THAT WALKED THE FACE OF THE
PLANET THERE WOULD CONTINUE TO
BE HURRICANES, BLIZZARDS, AND
TORNADOES.
THERE'S IN LOBBY THAT SHOULD BE
LAUGHED AT HARDER THAN THE
CLIMATE LOBBY, BECAUSE THEY KEEP
BEING WRONG.
WHEN I WAS A KID, I WAS TOLE IT
WAS GLOBAL WARMING.
HIDE UNDER YOUR DESKS, KIDS, THE
POLAR BEARS ARE GOING TO DROWN
BECAUSE THERE'S GLOBAL WARMING.
THEY STOPPED USING THAT LANGUAGE
AROUND 2011, BECAUSE
ACCIDENTALLY THE EARTH STARTED
TO COOL AND DISPROVE THEIR
NARRATIVE.
BEFORE MY GENERATION, THERE WAS
A GENERATION THAT SAID THAT
GLOBAL COOLING WOULD END THE
WORLD, BUT THEY WERE WRONG AND
THE EARTH STARTED TO WARM.
THERE WAS THE HOLE IN THE OZONE
LAYER.
WHOOPS.
THAT WASN'T ACTUALLY A TRAGEDY.
THEY MOVED ON.
THERE WAS THE ACIDIC OCEAN.
THERE'S GOING TO BE ACIDIC
OCEANS, BECAUSE THE RAIN WAS
ACIDIC.
WHOOPS.
THAT DIDN'T HAPPEN.
THEY MOVED ON.
THEY'VE BEEN WRONG OVER AND OVER
AGAIN.
YET THEY LOOK IN THE FACE WHEN A
NATURAL DISASTER STRIKES AND
TELL YOU, WE'VE NEVER ONCE GOT
IT RIGHT, BUT GIVE US YOUR MONEY
ANYWAYS.
THESE PEOPLE ARE SICK.
>> Tucker: I COMPLETELY AGREE
WITH THAT.
IN YOU KNOW, PEOPLE'S KOOKY
THEORIES DON'T BOTHER ME, BUT IF
YOU TRY TO TAKE OVER WE HAVE A
RIGHT TO FIGHT BACK.
NO?
>> AN ABSOLUTE RIGHT TO FIGHT
BACK.
WE NEED TO START IN THE
EDUCATION SYSTEM.
MY MIND WAS POLLUTED ABOUT
GLOBAL WARMING, BECAUSE THEY SAT
US OUT IN HEALTH CLASS AND MADE
US WATCH "INCONVENIENT TRUTH" BY
AL GORE.
THAT WAS A LIE.